♪ ♪
>> Lisa: WHETHER YOU ARE
COOKING THE TURKEY TOMORROW ARE
JUST SIMPLY SHOWING UP, RAYMOND
AND LAURA HAVE GOT YOU COVERED
WITH THANKSGIVING DOS AND
DON'TS.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I CAN TELL YOU EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO KNOW.
>> Laura: OKAY.
>> I'VE STUDIED THIS, RESEARCH
DEAD, AND I'VE LIVED THROUGH THE
DRAMA OF THANKSGIVINGS.
>> Laura: RAYMOND OF ALL
TRADES.
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST DON'T FOR
THANKSGIVING?
>> HERE IS ONE THING, DON'T
CREATE A FAMILY-WIDE FAST WHERE
YOU DEPRIVE THE PEOPLE IN THE
FAMILY OF FOOD ALL DAY LONG
UNTIL YOU ARE READY.
I'M JUST TELLING YOU, LADIES, I
LOVE YOU ALL, MEN DO NOT LIKE TO
GO ALL DAY WITHOUT EATING.
IF THEY GET ANGRY --
>> Laura: YOU DO.
>> I DO, I ADMIT IT.
THAT CAUSES ALL KINDS OF
PROBLEMS OF THE TABLE.
IF YOU WANT A SULLEN, QUIET MEAL
BECAUSE EVERYONE IS CARVING ON
THE FOOD, DO THAT.
MY ADVICE, PUT FINGER SANDWICHES
OUT, LET THEM EAT AROUND 1:00,
2:00, SO THEY ARE NOT ANGRY
BEARS.
>> Laura: I HAVE A QUESTION,
WHO MAKES FINGER SANDWICHES
STILL?
THAT IS SOMETHING MY GRANDMOTHER
MADE.
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
>> WHEN YOU ARE COOKING SIX OR
SEVEN COURSES, BUYING FINGER
SANDWICHES IS EASY.
>> Laura: MY MOTHER LEFT NOTES
AND STUFF OUT, EMINEM SPRAYED >>
A FAMILY OF SQUIRRELS?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Laura: THE BIG OLD FASHION
CRACKER, CRACKING THE NUTS.
WE WOULD GET INTO A FIGHT --
>> WHAT I THINK GIVING YOU MUCH
HAVE HAD.
"BREAK OUT THE NUTCRACKER,
KIDS."
>> Laura: MY MOTHER WOULD
START PLAYING THE POLISH
CHRISTMAS CAROLS.
NOW I ACTUALLY LOVE THEM, BUT AS
A KID, WE WOULD BE ROCKING
AROUND --
>> NO BRENDA LEE AT YOUR HOUSE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Laura: I AM SO SORRY.
SHE WAS SO GREAT.
IT WOULD BE LIKE -- [LAUGHS]
>> LIKE A POLISH FUNERAL.
THOSE HYMNS ARE A LITTLE DREARY,
I ADMIT.
WE GOT TO GET OUR -- DON'T COOK
A TURKEY IF YOU DON'T KNOW HOW
TO COOK A TURKEY.
DISASTER CAN ENSUE AND YOU HAD A
QUICK DON'T.
>> Laura: DON'T TRY A RECIPE
ON THANKSGIVING FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
[LAUGHS]
IS A TERRIBLE THING TO DO.
>> IS A TERRIBLE IDEA.
>> Laura: I HAD THE BRIGHT
IDEA OF MAKING AN APPLE
CRANBERRY PIE FOR THANKSGIVING.
MY MOTHER WAS -- SHE WAS AN
UNBELIEVABLE COOK BUT ESPECIALLY
OF FIVE.
>> SHE WAS LIKE MARIE CALENDAR
>> Laura: NO WAY TO REPLICATE
WHAT MY MOTHER DID.
I MADE THIS THING, I WAS ROLLING
IT OUT, ROLLING IT OUT --
>> THE THING YOU DON'T WANT TO
DO, YOU NEVER WANT TO OVERCOOK
ANYTHING, PARTICULARLY THE BIRD.
WATCH.
♪ ♪
>> LOOK AT THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT IS LIKE THE PUFF OF SMOKE
AT THE END.
>> Laura: SO DRY.
I DIDN'T GET TO FINISH MY STORY.
>> YOU CAN FINISH THAT IN THE
BOOK.
THE OTHER THING YOU DON'T WANT
TO DO IS TO CREATE MOISTURE.
PEOPLE THINK, PUT MORE GREASE OR
ALL OF OIL IN THE PAN THAT YOU
ARE COOKING THE BURDEN.
IT NEVER WORKS.
>> [LAUGHS]
♪ ♪
[LAUGHTER]
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
QUITE THAT BAD.
BUT SOME OF THESE JUST GO UP IN
FLAMES.
>> Laura: MY MOTHER USED TO
SAY -- I ALWAYS THINK OF HER
THIS TIME OF YEAR, I MISS HER A
LOT -- PEOPLE EAT FAST AND THEN
THEY JUST LEAVE THE TABLE.
I SLAVED ALL DAY WITH MY
CRIPPLED HANDS --
[LAUGHTER]
>> THE OTHER THING I WOULD
RECOMMEND PEOPLE DO BEFORE WE
GET TO THIS NEXT CLIP, MAKE SURE
YOU SPREAD THE PAIN AT YOUR
HOLIDAY TABLE.
THAT MEANS, SEPARATE THE
DISGRUNTLED MEMBER OF THE FAMILY
WHO MIGHT DIVIDE.
PUT THEM FAR AWAY FROM ONE
ANOTHER.
>> Laura: HOW ABOUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY?
>> EVEN BETTER, TO SEPARATE
THEM.
YOU ARE THINKING WAY AHEAD.
EVEN IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE A
VOLUNTEER AT THE MACY'S
THANKSGIVING DAY PARADE, MAKE
SURE THAT YOU HAVE A WORKOUT
ROUTINE OR WHERE HEAVYWEIGHT OR
OTHERWISE THIS CAN LEAD TO
CATASTROPHE.
>> Laura: I NEVER WAS A FAN OF
BARNEY.
IF ONE BALLOON HAD TO GO AWAY,
THAT IS THE ONE.
>> HE SLAMMED INTO A LIGHT POLE
BECAUSE THE WOMEN COULDN'T HOLD
HIM DOWN.
ACROSS SEVENTH AVENUE.
>> Laura: IT IS A LOT OF WORK
FOR PEOPLE TO PUT ON A
THANKSGIVING DINNER.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO